the justice department is filing an
anti-trust lawsuit
against google these cases represent the
biggest challenge to date to google's
dominance in online advertising
its most lucrative domain how did the
politically powerful company end up in
the crosshairs of federal regulators
the search for answers takes us to the
dawn of the new millennium
that's when regulators were making their
first major effort to rein
in the power of big tech and with some
success
in 2002 the justice department won an
anti-trust lawsuit against microsoft for
monopolizing its market
bill gates offered an argument other
tech titans would later echo
we don't think this decision matches the
reality of the high technology industry
you see a new moment when federal
regulators are willing to step up and
pursue these cases
laura phillip sawyer researches the
history of antitrust regulation at the
university of georgia law school
so this gives netscape a moment to
gain market share and firefox
come online five years later state and
federal anti-trust enforcers accused
microsoft of failing to comply with the
settlement
and this time a tech insurgent named
google
alleged that microsoft's operating
system was anti-competitive
google complained it was unfair of
microsoft to only allow customers to do
desktop searches
using windows software microsoft
relented and allowed in rival search
engines
but google's own regulatory issues would
soon emerge
in 2008 the justice department's
anti-trust division scuttled a proposed
partnership between google and yahoo
federal investigators said it would give
google too much power in online
advertising
and so regulators intervened and said
the subtext here is it looks like that
this
is going to disincentivize yahoo from
investing
in its yahoo search which should be a
competitor to google
search yahoo struck a deal with
microsoft the following year to handle
sales of search ads for both companies
but combined microsoft and yahoo
accounted for less than half
of google's share of searches as a
global tech behemoth
google didn't only have to worry about
u.s regulators
in 2010 google became the european
union's premier corporate target
the eu zeroed in on the company's core
search and advertising businesses
the investigation would take years to
unfold
good afternoon thank you all for coming
in 2013
the ftc which had spent nearly two years
probing google
decided not to bring charges it
concluded that there was
insufficient evidence to support
complaints that the 15 year old company
favors its own services and search
results google agreed to make voluntary
changes to its search practices
with today's action by the ftc google
can refocus on its business and its
products but with a clear understanding
that it too
uh must do so while competing fairly so
the ftc decided against pursuing the
case but they did state very explicitly
that they would keep an eye on this
industry and they would return to it as
the cases developed
the following year google scored another
victory it reached a deal with european
commission regulators to tweak the way
it presents search results
google agreed to give rival services
comparable prominence but that wasn't
the end of the story
far from it just three years later we
start with the breaking news that the
internet giant google
has been hit with a record 2.42 billion
euro fine for breaching eu competition
rules the eu concluded that google's
search is dominant
and that meant google was violating
european law by putting its own product
ads
on top of search results from other
sites that offered
the same products a little more than a
year later european regulators slapped
google with
another fine this time the eu ordered
google to pay
5 billion for abusing the dominance of
its android mobile platform
back in the us big tech's political
fortunes were also turning
a republican-controlled white house in
congress viewed these companies growing
power
including in the marketplace of ideas
with suspicion
and for you to come in here and say
there is no political
bias in google tells us you
either are being dishonest i don't want
to think that
or you don't have a clue how politically
biased google
is google's ceo since 2015 sundar pachai
staunchly refuted these accusations in
his first congressional appearance
i lead this company without political
bias and work to ensure that our
products continue to operate that way
google's most lucrative product online
advertising kept on growing
its annual ad revenue had surpassed a
hundred billion dollars
when the wall street journal broke the
news that the justice department was
preparing an
anti-trust investigation of google just
a few months later
google took another blow today
50 attorney generals from different
states and territories
are launching an investigation into
google's potential monopolistic
behavior it was against the backdrop of
these investigations that pachai
and his tech ceo peers testified
remotely this summer before congress
pichai sounded a familiar theme
new competitors emerge every day and
today users have more
access to information than ever before
competition drives us to innovate and it
also leads to better products
legal scholars observe that since the
1970s anti-trust enforcement has focused
on harm to the consumer
how's the consumer affected by the cost
of advertising
i think it's going to be difficult to
prove consumer harm
i mean the way in which it could be done
might be
demonstrating that prices for
advertising is higher and that has
some knock-on effects but experts say
the cases against google
could signal a new era in enforcement
and curtailing the power of big tech
companies
a google spokesperson said the company
would continue to engage with ongoing
investigations
and that its services enable increased
choice and competition